[Music]
so many celebrities inspired us over at
et this year including social media
Queen Selena Gomez of course celeb
do-gooder Taylor Swift I want to read
some stuff off to you guys she donated
five thousand dollars to fan to a fans
funeral costs and then most recently she
donated a hundred thousand dollars to
those affected by the Tennessee
wildfires of course Dolly Parton start
of that but to me you guys Taylor Swift
say what you will about her she donates
a lot and she cares about people and to
me that's why she gets this award do you
agree yeah well it's hard sometimes
because you know of course what do we
love to hear about her love life I mean
man this year was a year of Tom
Hiddleston of a calvin harris breakup
and we are gonna be doing Facebook lives
on the biggest stories of the years the
biggest scandals of the years and the of
the year and yet Taylor's gonna be in
that but we can't forget the good that
she has done and a celebrity that is
such a good example to set and then we
wanted to want to head over into another
young lady who we are giving the social
media Queen award to you you're a big
fan hey guys there's no question this
has to go to Selena Gomez she is the
most followed celebrity on Instagram
she's over 104 million followers this
picture of her with it's a coca-cola ad
has over six million likes it was the
most liked photo of 2016 and here's why
it's a little bit crazy she took a long
hiatus this year she went away for three
months she came back she made this red
carpet debut at the American Music
Awards she looked flawless and then she
gave a speech about how she doesn't want
social media to define her yet here she
is the social media Queen you see these
pictures of her and her fans and she's
just inspiring about it well like you
said the most followers on Instagram
more than Taylor Swift more than Katy
Perry more than the car dash right and
Justin Bieber yes is not even on
Instagram anymore deleted his Instagram
this year you were so moved by her
speech when she came back at the
americanized cried a little bit just cuz
I was so proud of her and I'd
interviewed Selena Gomez many times and
just to see how beautiful she was to get
up
and deliver that was so much class
that's what she's all about and that's
why I think she is one of the biggest
celebrities in the world
you